but for us to be really productive
there are couple of things that we also need to be aware of
especially if you are currently exploring multiple tools
I call them developer AI Fatigue Toolkit
let us take a look at some of the tips and tools that will help us
in order for us to really manage our AI fatigue
the first is Timebox AI programming
and what does this mean
you need to be able to tell when AI should do the work
and when you should do the work
in my previous videos I stated that it is very important that we know
which task AI should help us to do
and which tasks are we supposed to do by ourselves
in some instances
you spend time trying to bend the AI to do the right thing
because you are giving the AI the task that you're supposed to do
so something you need to do
for example you could say maybe you use a particular minute to code
you use a particular minute to think
and finally use some minutes to have some break or just relax
for example you can have maybe 25 minutes to use coding assistance
another 10 minutes for thinking
and finally use another five minutes for break
when you break down some of these things
the break may not be something very huge
it could just be you strolling or just walking around
whatever it is but the point is you use agents
you think and you rest when you mix these things intermittently
you understand that yes
some of these things are not as difficult as they may be